so in this section we are going to talk
about genome assembly using repairs
power give great lectures explaining how
to construct the brain graph from reads
in from the obtain the blue graph he
explained how to find an alluring path
in this graph to identify the genome but
he forgot to tell you one important
thing
there can be multiple learning paths in
the Depot ingre even in this symbol
debris graph there are two Alerian paths
in this graph here they are and these
two are learning paths correspond to two
different strings which string are you
going to give to biologists the left one
or the right one or both please note
that we sequence only one genome well
this ambiguity froze us to decompose the
deployment graph into multiple
disconnected components each component
correspond to a non-printing path in the
Dupre graph please note that why they're
multiple Alerian paths in the rippln
graph all of them share the same set of
non-printing paths shown here these
non-printing paths in their turn
correspond to contexts which are sub
strings in the genome well ideally
biologists would like to have one
context for each assembly or at least
one should significantly reduce the
number of contexts to obtain this go
they invented the technology concrete
pair sequencing that I'm going to talk
about given multiple identical copies of
the same genome we now randomly cut
these genomes into large equally sized
fragment of size insert length
now for each fragment we generate pair
of reads from both end of each fragment
so now instead of
talking about reeds individually we are
talking about pair of reeds separated by
a distance can exercise so given two
camels if they are at a fixed distance D
apart in the genome we call them a pair
cameras so the question is how to
construct the genome not from the
chemical composition like previously
described but from paired k-mer
composition but what is paired k-mer
composition given a string a paired
k-mer composition of a string is a set
of all paired k-mers generated from this
string well because we don't have space
let's represent a pair of camera as a to
lie expression like this okay we can
order these pair cameras in this order
which is the order that they were
generated from the genome but please
note that the position information is
not available so a correct way to
represent the paired k-mer composition
should be in lexicographic order like in
a dictionary so the question now is can
you construct the string given its
paired k-mer composition oh let me
describe formally input is a collection
of pair cameras output is a string text
search that the paired k-mer composition
of stacks is equal to the collection of
pair cameras how would you solve this
let's ask the problem
how would he solve this problem well I
think that the fluent would came up with
the same approach that I'm going to
describe right now which is the pair
previa
given a genome and it's pair chemical
composition it's clear that the genome
can be represented
as a path where the edges are labeled by
paired k-mers and the notes can be
labeled by pair of K minus ones and this
path we call it genome path but allow me
to do one crazy operation with this
genome path
let me glue nodes with identical labels
together in this light we have two nodes
with identical label PGA T we glue them
with glue and this graph is called the
paragraph from the genome now you may
guess that the next question I'm going
to ask is can you construct repair the
printer not from the genome but from the
pair came up compositions of the genome
well the answer let's see how we solve
this problem let's represent each paired
k-mers by an edge from the pair prefix
to the paired cervix now let's do the
same thing as the bloom graph we glue
notes with identical labels together
here we glue quick Lu continue gluing
continue continue continue what is it
this is the genome path as if the genome
was available but it's not all we have
something more to glue pvat t'get they
tune their two nodes with identical
label we have to glue them we clue this
is the paragraph from the read pairs
okay to recap the paragraph for
collection of paired k-mers can be
constructed by two operations first
represent every pair came us as an ash
between its prayer prefix and pair
suffix second glue our nodes with
identical labels in the paragraph the
genome is an alluring walk in the
paragraph but what is the point in the
different graph we also have this
property the genome is also an alluring
work in this in the deployment but
please note that in the paragraph nodes
are labeled by pair of K minus 1 months
Y in the deployment graph nodes are
labeled by just individual K minus 1
month both of these graphs can be
obtained by gluing operations on the
genome path but because of this the
difference in the labeling paragraph is
obtained by fewer gluings and that makes
it simpler in this case you can see that
the paragraph is simpler than the
DePrima graph indeed there's only one or
Larian path in the paragraph that allow
us to uniquely construct the genome why
the deployment graph we cannot construct
the genome uniquely in practice peddling
graph has been applied in assemblers and
it has shown significant advantage in
the resulting assembly